I've been telling you for some time that
the damage Donald Trump is doing in the
u.s. is going to outlast his presidency
and this is true both in terms of the
practical and the ideological so as an
example the way in which Trump has
course and political language and what
counts as discourse is going to outlast
Donald Trump that won't be fixed when
Trump leaves office but a more practical
example is that things like the
alliances with other countries that
Trump has ruined will take longer to fix
than Donald Trump's tenure in office it
could take years after Trump has gone to
repair those alliances with other
countries with international
institutions and working groups David
Frum a traditional conservative I guess
we'd call him he was a speechwriter for
George W Bush he wrote an article about
exactly this in the Atlantic called
America after Trump and he points out a
lot of the ways in which Trump's damage
to America is going to last longer than
his presidency one example is even
though Republicans before Trump have won
the electoral college without winning
the popular vote Trump lost the popular
vote by the biggest margin in history
while still winning the electoral
college in 2016 that's likely to happen
again if Trump gets reelected in 2020
and the more that that losing margin is
in the popular vote while still winning
the electoral from argues will call into
question the legitimacy of our political
system and I agree and I've been talking
about the electoral college for a long
time and from goes on to say if Trump
loses narrowly in 2020 the 40% of the
country that likes him is likely to turn
into organized violence which will be
destructive to our country's social
fabric for a very long time maybe Trump
will try to get the military involved to
keep him in office because he feels that
he was cheated now the military is not
going to do that but simply a president
publicly pushing for that would be
disastrous for the country and it would
allow Trump to keep harming the United
States beyond November of 2020
now if Trump loses big as David Frum
says the possibility of Democrats fixing
everything and quickly is really slim
and we have to recognize that there is
going to be a lot to fix and
unfortunately the reality is that this
takes
long time even a much more left-wing
president than we've ever had before if
it's Bernie if it's Warren they're not
going to be able to do everything and
fix everything in four years and this
will potentially make people even more
disaffected with the political system
because they'll say look Trump was
terrible but we got him out and we put
in Bernie or Warren and they barely
fixed anything because it's of course
much easier to break things than it is
to build them as we know and then there
are things david frum doesn't talk about
in his piece i've talked about the
justice system the judiciary the damage
done by donald trump's supreme court and
lower court justice and judge selections
is already disgusting and it will
continue and it will persist for a long
time because those are positions for
life and they are going to outlast Trump
by a lot the damage of the environmental
regulations that were rolled back or
skipped may never be undone and every
day we fall further and further behind
where we could be we don't make progress
we don't deal with the environmental
issue that's by design this is what they
want but it will damage the country long
beyond Donald Trump's presidency this is
just a partial list but the idea is to
really make clear that we do not fix the
problems merely by getting rid of Trump
that's like one a the prerequisite to
start thinking about all of the things
that will need to be fixed there are
people on the Left who recognize it
there are people on the right like David
Frum who recognize it and we all need to
understand that that the removal of
Trump in 2020 is not the solution it's
merely step one in starting to repair
things let me know what you think I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman follow me there
we'll take a quick break and be back
right after this